Let's go back to the documentation for
the OnClickListener.
As we're starting to realize, Android
is very specific about the details
around how to listen for an input event.
The method can't be named anything else.
It needs to be precisely on click and
have exactly
one input which is the view being
clicked on and have no return value.
So you can think of this outline
here of the OnClickListener
regarding the class and the methods
as a contract that you as a developer
need to follow in order to be
notified of the click events.
In more formal Java terms,
this is the definition of an interface.
At the top of this documentation page,
in small font, it says interface.
In the future, its highly
likely that you may come across
another component in Android
that is also an interface.
So at this point,
you may be wondering, wait a minute, how
was an interface different from a class?
The document pages look pretty similar.
Well, in the last course,
we learned about classes like text view,
which contains state and methods
that are fully implemented, meaning,
there are instructions in each method.
Now we're being introduced
interfaces which contain no state,
but it does contain method signatures.
Remember that a method signature
signifies the return value, method name,
and input parameters.
It ends with a semicolon and
there are no curly braces,
with the code in the middle for
implementation of the method.
This means it's an abstract method.
An abstract method's implementation
is intentionally left blank so
that a developer like you who
wants to use the interface
can provide their own
specific instructions for it.
So it's like saying,
fill in the blank for
what you want to happen when
this view is clicked on.
There can be multiple abstract methods
in an interface, but this example of
the onClickListener interface only has
one abstract method, the onClick method.
In the future,
we'll also encounter abstract classes.
This is a partially implemented
class and it contains state and
some methods are fully implemented while
other methods are left abstract for
someone else to define the behavior.
So you can think of this as
a continuum where an interface is not
implemented at all, and abstract
class is partially implemented, and
a concrete class is fully implemented.
So how come an on click listener
is not a concrete class?
And why isn't a text view an interface?
And the same with the view
group being an abstract class.
The Android team made these
respective decisions,
based on what would make it easier for
developers, like you, to build an app.
Every developer will need to
display text on the screen.
So they created a concrete text
view class that accomplishes that.
We can simply call methods to
change the text in the view.
So in this abstract class case, we want
to standardize some behavior about
view groups being a container
of multiple child views.
However, the details of
how to lay out the views
on the screen is left undefined for
the subclass to determine.
In this case, when your layout and
relative layout are subclasses
of the ViewGroup class,
they each define their own rules for how
views should be laid out on the screen.
On the other hand, the Android team
knows that many developers will probably
want to customize the click behavior.
It wouldn't make sense to
provide default behavior for
what happens when a button is clicked.
But the Android team did want to
standardize what the method call would
be and the cost type would
be in on click listener.
Then they leave the logic
inside the method for
the developer to write themselves.
So to summarize,
if you come across a concrete class
in Android you can use it right away.
If you come across an abstract class,
you need to subclass this and
then provide your own code for
the abstract methods.
If you come across an interface,
you need to provide for
all the abstract methods.